cyberpunk 2077 reveals its first
expansion PlayStation 5 is getting some
new accessories and is Naughty Dog
teasing its next franchise all this on
today's Gamespot news
cyberpunk unveiled its first paid DLC
today let's get the bad news out of the
way it won't be coming to previous gen
consoles Phantom Liberty launches in
2023 and brings back Keanu Reeves Johnny
silverhand for another adventure
described as a spy Thriller expansion
that introduces a new cast of characters
Phantom Liberty takes place in a new
previously unexplored District in night
City the new 1.6 update that releases
today September 6th will be the final
significant patch for cyberpunk 2077 on
PS4 and Xbox One this update adds
equippable items from the cyberpunk edge
Runners anime to the game a handful of
new side quests as well as highly
requested features such as transmogging
and cross progression a full rundown of
everything included in the patch can be
found in the link in the description
there will be small patches for previous
gen consoles going forward to address
bugs and other fixes but no new content
will be added to those versions of the
game and those who picked up the limited
edition bundle for Xbox One at launch
will receive a reimbursement for the
expansion in the form of Microsoft Store
credits between now and the Phantom
Liberty DLC CD project red also promised
some other long requested adjustments
such as changes to police behavior and
car combat to come in future updates at
the end of the day it's probably for the
best that CD projekt Red is ceasing
development for the previous generation
of consoles as cyberpunk's launch on
them was a disaster even resulting in
the game being temporarily delisted from
the PlayStation Network store speaking
of PlayStation the PlayStation 5 is
getting a camo makeover Sony has
revealed a new set of designs for its
PS5 Hardware dual sense controller and
pulse 3D headset which it calls the gray
camouflage collection unlike the default
White model PS5 or its more vibrant
selection of console cover plates this
design will wrap the console in a
camouflage design that makes the device
great for grabbing someone's attention
and hiding it in case a wall breaks out
on an overcast day Sony says that
pre-orders will begin on September 15th
with the Dual sense wireless controller
and PS5 console covers launching
globally on October 14th the gray
camouflage pulse through the headset
will arrive later in December if you've
been playing The Last of Us Part 1 on
your PS5 keep an eye out for a specific
Easter egg that has fans thinking it's a
tease for Naughty dog's next game some
new art has cropped up in the remake
that isn't in the original game the art
shows a number of fantasy images one of
which shows a warrior facing a fire
breathing dragon another showing some
kind of snake-like Beast wrapped around
what looks to be a triangular shaped
Moon and another showing a horned
Pegasus this wouldn't be the first time
that naughty dog has teased one of its
future titles in its games when
Uncharted 3 launched in November 2011
fans quickly spotted a newspaper
clipping referencing The Last of Us
which was announced the following month
fans also speculated that the superhero
collectible cards in Last of Us Part 2
were a hint at the developers next
project
and that is it for today's Gamespot news
what did you think of today's cyberpunk
updates do you think you'd be into a
fantasy Naughty Dog game let us know in
the comments below and we'll see you
here tomorrow for more games fun news